[Music]
celebrating the war
this video purports to show russian
soldiers dancing before heading to the
front line in ukraine
the video is circulating on several
platforms and has been viewed thousands
of times
but the video isn't from ukraine it
dates from 2018 and shows a uzbekistan
military band at a concert in a
subway using a reverse image search we
found older versions of the video and
were able to locate it with google maps
we come across photos of a subway
station in tashkent uzbekistan not in
russia
ever since russia attacked ukraine
thousands of images and videos of battle
scenes have flooded the internet but be
careful what you share not everything is
real or what it appears to be
these images allegedly show russian jets
launching attacks however
the images are actually from the video
game armor 3.
it is by no means the first time that
such game sequences have been posted and
misused as combat images
we have seen similar examples during the
afghanistan crisis last year
however the case with the following
images is different
here we see a formation of fighter jets
flying over an urban area a twitter user
has written in chinese
live broadcasting of the war in ukraine
the reverse image search of a screenshot
reveals that the video dates back to
2020 and shows an air show north of
moscow
some users are seeking attention by
uploading old videos and sometimes the
media falls for it
this is what happened at the tv branch
of the german media outlet built
the images show hundreds of russian
soldiers allegedly parachuting over the
ukrainian city of kharkiv
as the presenter explains to us
but the footage is old we found the
exact same video on facebook dating back
to 2016.
the footage it appears is from russia
the assault on ukraine is not only
happening from the air but also on the
ground again don't believe everything
you see here
take this tick tock video it shows a
huge explosion allegedly stemming from
an attack in ukraine a day before the
russian invasion began
but what should you make suspicious is
that the trees and bushes are
surprisingly green for february in
ukraine
we also checked for older versions here
and found several narratives of the same
event via reverse image search
the video actually shows a gas station
in the siberian city of novosibirsk that
went up in flames last summer
so again here there is no link to the
war in ukraine
in conflict situations like the current
one between russia and ukraine we
encounter a flood of images on the
internet
some of them are fake so before you
share it's always better to look twice